that is horrifying
from concept to the complete picture
we're walking you through the process of
creating stranger things best most
practical villain yet vechna before
i kill you
i want you to are
number one read between the lines
stranger things are costing
we need to take by the end of the week
jamie was initially given sides for
primal fear and hellraiser not the
actual stranger things script having
some understanding of the films already
jaime knew that the character in primal
fear presents two versions of himself
there's this sort of sweet niceness to
him and then all of a sudden it sort of
comes this darkness so that's what jaime
did then the second tape he got sides
from the show then it was christmas and
i was like waiting like watching my
phone after new year's he got the email
matt and ross really want to make you
get on a plane come back to la now
number two evil genius much jaime's
mapping out of the character for his
second audition proved to be so in-depth
and so close to what the creators had
envisioned that it was almost uncanny
vecna is
chilling jaime had such a strong sense
of the character there was no way the
duffers could have gone with another
actor he said i went crazy for like two
days in my apartment i put a picture of
will byers in the middle and then all
the other characters around it and then
sort of made this claire danes-esque
from homeland mind map of who i thought
this person was i stepped back from it
after two days and was like that feels
kind of good so i took a picture and
then i printed out all the pictures and
put them in this little folder number
three perhaps the other vechnas exist in
alternate universes spin-off series
right vecna could have been a very
different beast from patchwork skin to
vampires to fish to praying mantises to
spiders the inspiration came from
everywhere and we were left with some
bone-chilling scrapped designs the
mantis is the coolest and closest to the
upside down in that its chest and arms
would have been able to split apart like
the demogorgons and demo dogs while the
creepiest was this guy number four maybe
the final design wasn't the coolest of
them but it was the closest to the
show's aesthetic we are basically
integrating lots of shapes and textures
and forms from the upside down the final
design was a nice mix of spider
metaphors translucent skin rotting flesh
and kept the asymmetrical arm while
still including all those elements of
the upside down number five of course
the full vacna suit wasn't the only
prosthetic jaime was donning there was
also dimension x vachna that was
somewhere between jaime and the final
monster form and when you've got a-list
actors on big sets you've also got
doubles doubling the time prosthetics
and manpower to get the artists ready
number six first comes the clay
sculpture then comes the molds the
plaster cast of jamie's body was painted
all over with a very important soap
product after it dried they sculpted
vechna over the top in wax modeling clay
to make it easier to put on and take off
the actor they needed to divide their
sculpture into different pieces and then
create separate molds of each piece but
to separate them you need to submerge
the whole body under water this is to
reactivate that base soap layer they
started with to get the plasticine off
of the under layer we bought this huge
paddling pool put it in our workshop and
it took a day to fill with water the
sculpt had to be submerged the entire
night to reactivate the soap they then
drilled holes into the back of the
sculpture so the water could just pour
right out then they could finally stand
it back up separate the pieces and then
create molds based on those pieces
number 7. living in the costume until
filming wrapped may have been easier the
8 hour process was whittled down to 6
hours and 20 minutes at least to get the
makeup on if it was like a 7am crew call
he would have to come in at
1am what it was a whole other two hours
to get it off at the end of the day
here's hoping jaime could sleep through
that or he'd never sleep at all his day
started at 3am to be ready for 10 am he
and the makeup artists would all chill
and listen to heavy rock music while the
prosthetics were being applied and jaime
would use the tone to get into character
otherwise he'd read a book and on rare
occasions sip on coffee for me you know
i'm a small cog in a very very big wheel
number eight paint me like one of your
vectors barry the concept art was great
but translating that to the real thing
was a challenge to find the right colors
they looked at different sea life and
human bruises they had an overwhelming
number of colors to choose from and
reeling it in was hard we had to really
hone it in to only a few colors they
settled on one makeup palette from
premiere products with 10 different
colors and that was it number nine gotta
stay sticky jamie was just covered in
lube and a wet looking gel to give vecna
a glossy look every day it would be four
dudes who would have about 15 minutes to
coat him with it and people would come
up and try and shake his hand and just
regret it immediately we can only wonder
how jaime feels under there he was given
dentures and contact lenses to finish it
off we really put him through the mill
there wasn't anything else we could get
on jamie number 10 got your nose jaime
not every part of vechna could be
practical unfortunately this isn't
2004's spider-man with doc ock this is
more like 2021's doc ock just let cgi
handle the inhuman stuff the living
vines were added in post none of that
was there so that was kind of just like
strain my arms and my neck to make it
look like there was something wrapped
around them that goes for not only
vacna's vines but all the vines our
heroes weren't jumping over anything
they were just jumping from tape mark to
tape mark on the floor it's like
hopscotch over imaginary vines it was
also up to the vfx team to remove
jaime's nose number 11. the asymmetry of
one large distorted hand was a welcome
challenge the first thing that that i
started to think about was the
physicality of this person they had to
reduce the length of the hand because
the concept art looked fantastic but in
practice the hand was coming off a bit
comical the next problem was when others
were trying it out after five minutes
they had hand cramps but jaime loved it
and had no struggle number 12 that voice
is all jaime's baby i saw a means to
realize my potential no voice
alterations were necessary to transcend
my human form but when he went in to do
the adr the sound guy almost didn't
believe that he wouldn't need
alterations at all because it was hard
to hear in the prosthetics he struggled
at first to refine the voice that he'd
worked on to become
the predator i was always born to be
number 13 this character would be enough
to stretch any actor
vecna's not some sea creature from the
deep his character is not chaos this is
one very certain and attentive character
the only thing scarier than a chaotic
villain is a calculated one the human
element's gone and between campbell's
very early mind map and his strong
understanding of the manipulative nature
of henry towards a young 11 he nailed
the two-faced side of henry and the
outright terrifying vechna number 14.
jaime was being that weirdo on set he
was wandering around decked out in
prosthetics glaring at people grunting
and growling to stay in character he was
kind of murmuring things under his
breath and you could tell he was
definitely getting into the vector zone
jamie knew that this was an already very
successful show before he came on board
so he knew to trust those in charge
encouraging them to let him know what he
can do to be in service to the material
saying that he holds no ego
number 15. poor jaime felt bad he was
freaking out the young kids you feel so
in the moment which is you know such a i
feel like that was such a luxury millie
bobby brown had no idea that vecna was
practical this season and it made her
cry blessed she burst into tears but it
kept her on her toes the fear was
genuine definitely very real i didn't
have to act
six plus hours in the makeup chair is
enough to drive anyone mad do you think
the design they landed on was the best
or would you have liked to see some more
of the concept art at play let us know
in the comments and thanks for hanging
out with us here at the things